die nachrichten des tages heute mit
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch kristin otto für den sport sehr
gern genannt ein politisch wichtiger tag
für deutschland
die ampel steht spd grüne und fdp legen
ihren koalitionsvertrag vor und
versprechen fortschritt und klimaschutz
geimpft gewesen getestet 3g bestimmt das
leben von millionen ab heute auch am
arbeitsplatz sowie in bussen und bahnen
und test für den ernstfall im all
erstmals soll absichtlich eine sonde in
einem asteoriden gesteuert werden um so
seine flugbahn zu verändern
knapp zwei monate nach der
bundestagswahl steht der
koalitionsvertrag von spd grünen und fdp
wenn jetzt die parteitage und bei den
grünen die mitglieder noch zustimmen
wird deutschland wie angekündigt noch
vor weihnachten erstmals von einem
ampelbündnis regiert es sei etwas
zusammengewachsen bei den verhandlungen
sagt der wohl künftige kanzler scholz
und kündigt ein jahrzehnt der
investitionen an wir werden zeigen dass
wohlstand und klimaschutz vereinbar sind
verspricht grünen-chef habeck fdp chef
lindner redet von außerordentlich
ambitionierten vorhaben was das konkret
heißt zeigt thomas reichert
60 tage nach der bundestagswahl nimmt
die ampel aufstellung um nach wochen der
geheimhaltung sich selbst und ihren
koalitionsvertrag zu präsentieren doch
mitten in der vierten der schwersten
corona welle geht es für die ampel
zuerst um anderes scholz kündigte an
einen corona krisenstab einen pflege
bonus von einer milliarde euro und eine
impfpflicht in bestimmten bereichen ich
weiß wir hatten alle die hoffnung dass
dieser winter kein kroner winter werden
gemeinsam haben wir es in der hand diese
schlimme vierte welle zu brechen die
neue bundesregierung wird alles
erforderliche tun um unser land gut
durch diese zeit zu bringen mehr
fortschritt wagen verspricht der
koalitionsvertrag der ampel 177 seiten
lang mit einem zu die grünen zentralen
versprechen deutschland soll bis
spätestens 2005 und 40 klimaneutral
werden erneuerbare energien sollen auf
80 prozent des strombedarfs ausgebaut
werden und der kohleausstieg soll
vorgezogen werden idealerweise bis 2030
kern dieser neuen geschichte die wir
zusammen schreiben können ist die
vereinbarkeit von wohlstand und
klimaschutz wie ein roter faden zieht
sich der gedanke durch das gegensätze
durch eine neue politik sich ergänzen
können überwunden werden können die
ampel verspricht soziale verbesserungen
massive investitionen in klimaschutz und
gleichzeitig die einhaltung der
schuldenbremse der digitale ausbau soll
beschleunigt werden es soll schnellere
planungs und genehmigungsverfahren geben
zum beispiel für windräder und höhere
bildungsausgaben
christian lindner hat nach den langen
verhandlungsrunden noch ein bekenntnis
parat dass man bei ihm kaum erwartet
hätte
olaf scholz verfügt über ein inneres
geländer
um aus einer klare werthaltung heraus
dieses land nach vorne zu führen und
weit mehr menschen zu repräsentieren als
nur sozialdemokratisch grün oder liberal
gewählt haben und deshalb wird olaf
scholz ein starker bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland sein ein
bündnis für freiheit gerechtigkeit und
nachhaltigkeit verspricht die ampel
diesem bündnis müssen nun erst mal die
drei parteien selbst zustimmen
fragen wir unseren
hauptstadtkorrespondenten theo koll
robert habeck hat gesagt sie würden eine
regierung sein die anderen menschen
etwas zumutet wie mutig ist dieser
koalitionsvertrag nun er ist mutig und
feige zugleich mutig oder besser
vielleicht entschlossen ist er in der
form wie er beispielsweise die
klimakrise angehen will also erneuerbare
energien sollen bis
2030 80 prozent ausmachen planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren sollen dafür
deutlich beschleunigt werden und vieles
mehr couragiert ist auch beispielsweise
ein neues einbürgerungsrecht anzustreben
unter anderem jahr mit einem
punktesystem als eine art zweite säule
der 1 wanderung für fachkräfte das
gegenteil von mutig aber beispielsweise
sind die aussagen zur rente da
garantiert man das derzeitige niveau
aber der kleine neuer aktien anteil der
wird dafür nicht reichen und nicht
unproblematisch könnte auch die
mitfinanzierung des gesamthaushalts über
schuldenaufnahme und investitionen bei
bundesbehörden werden aber das feld eher
in die kategorie vernebelung danke für
den moment theo koll wir sprechen gleich
weiter schauen zunächst aber auf die
künftigen ministerinnen und minister
noch sind die personalien nicht
offiziell bestätigt aber die
ressortverteilung frank buchwald details
olaf scholz kurz vor dem ziel der spd
mann aus hamburg wird bundeskanzler als
erster an der spitze einer
ampel-koalition mit großen zielen
es geht uns nicht um eine politik des
kleinsten gemeinsamen nenners sondern um
eine politik der großen wirkung der neue
kanzler keine überraschung im kabinett
aber ändert sich manches sechs
ministerien gehen an die spd vier an die
fdp 5 an die grünen vize kanzler soll
robert habeck werden er übernimmt wo das
wirtschafts ressort erweitert um den
klimaschutz ein superministerium und er
beginnt mit einem versprechen
gegensätze können überwunden werden
durch eine lernende politik ein
lernendes deutschland eine lernende
politik das ist das versprechen dass wir
uns gegen die co vorsitzende der grünen
annalena baerbock soll außenministerin
werden als erste frau an der spitze des
außenamtes das mächtige
finanzministerium geht dann fdp chef
christian lindner er steht zur
schuldenbremse und setzt auf
wirtschaftliche freiheit ich bin unserem
land sowie private initiative privates
know how und privates kapital
das wir nun endlich entfesseln wollen um
unseren weg fortzusetzen in eine
dekarbonisierung digitalisierte
technologie nation die in der lage ist
wohlstand und wachstum für mehr menschen
zu organisieren
auch an die spitze des
justizministeriums rückt nach acht
jahren wieder ein liberaler marco
buschmann
die bisherige justizministerin christine
lambrecht von der spd könnte das
innenministerium übernehmen leicht aber
war es für die ampel wohl nicht sich
zusammenzuraufen dreier konstellation
kann sich niemand zu 100 prozent
durchsetzen was aber eine möglichkeit
gibt auch mal den standpunkt zu wechseln
und zu verstehen dass wenn christian
lindner eine 6 auf der seite sieht und
welche einen neuen sehen dass wir
vielleicht beide recht haben können und
wir nur bereit sein müssen weil die
sichtweise des anderen
drei partner ein neuer ton neue ziele in
berlin beginnt eine zeit großer
hoffnungen sie müssen sich bald im
regierungsalltag bewährt
jetzt liegen die pläne der ampel auf dem
tisch theo koll wie sind die ersten
reaktionen
die sind erwartbar so unterschiedlich
wie diejenigen die sich den appell
vertrag vorknöpfen für die linke ist
diese koalition ein fortschritt für
gutverdiener und superreiche hieß es
eben für die afg dagegen ein linkes
projekt mit der fdp als der nathan
hensel auch die csu sieht in dem
koalitionsvertrag die geburtsurkunde
einer links gelben koalition und die cdu
kann den aufbruch darin nicht erkennen
kritik zielt unter anderem auf das thema
migration aber kritik gibt es auch an
der klimapolitik kreide ist future
eltern entwurf für nicht ausreichend und
greenpeace bemängelt der verkehr werde
absehbar zum problemfall der ampel beim
klimaschutz fazit da der entwurf für
alle drei ampel parteien der etwas
beinhaltet hält er eben auch für jeden
kritiker etwas bereit dankeschön nach
berlin theo koll
robert habeck und christian lindner sind
gleich nach uns zu gast bei was nun im
anschluss gibt es ein zdf spezial und in
unsere zdf heute app haben wir weitere
details zusammengefasst vom wahlrecht ab
16 bis zum
heizkostenzuschuss
dringend der aufgabe der neuen regierung
bleibt der kampf gegen korona da
schießen die zahlen weiter nach oben zum
ersten mal legt heute die 7 tage
incidence über 400 und zwar bei 404,5
das lka meldet 66
1884 neuinfektionen 14.000 58 mehr als
vergangenen mittwoch 3 135 tote kamen
hinzu
gleichzeitig kommt das impfen wieder in
schwung gestern gab es so viele
impfungen wie seit ende juli nicht
nämlich 600 38.000 darunter sind 84.000
menschen die sich erstmals impfen ließen
ein zwei monats höchststand
im kampf gegen die pandemie gilt ab
heute auch das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz 3g regeln
inklusive reist zugang zum arbeitsplatz
bekommt nur wer geimpft genesen oder
getestet ist entsprechend groß war wie
hier in elmshorn der ansturm auf die
testzentren viele wollten vor
arbeitsbeginn noch schnell den nötigen
nachweis holen schnell ging's meisten
aber nicht vielerorts gab es
stundenlange wartezeiten
egal ob bus oder bahn auch wer
öffentliche verkehrsmittel nutzt muss
seit heute geimpft genesen oder getestet
sein sonst droht das ende der fahrt und
ein hohes bußgeld
oliver deuker zeigt wie das heute an
lief auch mit den kontrollen
münchen überprüfen der ab heute
bundesweit geltenden 3g pflicht im
öffentlichen personenverkehr rausreden
kann sich niemand auf videoleinwänden
und anzeigetafeln werden die fahrgäste
wie hier in hannover über die 3g pflicht
informiert reaktionen ich finde das gut
weil die bahn einfach viel zu voll sind
also ich fühle mich da sicher ich würde
es gut ich finde die politik reagiert
immer viel zu spät ich finde es an sich
okay ich glaube die umsetzung wird halt
sehr schwierig werden denn bei der
polizei und den ordnungsämtern fehlt
dafür personal so wird es statt
flächendeckenden nur stichproben
kontrollen geben die zum größten teil
mitarbeiter der verkehrsbetriebe
übernehmen also wer da völlig
unkooperativ ist bei diesen
überprüfungen
ein zertifikat nachweisen kann nichts
vorlegen kann oder sich weigert dann
wenn wir den natürlich erst mal heraus
bitten weil wir ihn nicht mehr weiter
befördern dürfen und dann werden wir die
polizei rufen um die personalien
festzustellen damit dort dann
gegebenenfalls ein ordnungsgeld verhängt
werden kann 3g kontrollen auch in den
zügen der deutschen bahn befördert
werden darf auch hier nur wer
vollständig geimpft ist die impfung muss
mindestens 14 tage zurückliegen der
genesen ist nicht länger als sechs
monate oder getestet mit antigen
schnelltests unter aufsicht nicht älter
als 24 stunden sowie ein aktueller
pcr-test ein selbsttest reicht nicht sie
erfüllt die 3g pflicht nicht muss
aussteigen soll sich testen lassen nach
dem infektionsschutzgesetz kann das bis
zu 2500 euro kosten ende november wollen
sich die bundesländer über ein
einheitliches bußgeld verständigen
gegen den fdp politiker björn fecker
kann ermittelt werden der
justizausschuss des thüringer landtags
hat die immunität des chefs der afg
fraktion aufgehoben röcke soll eine
wahlkampfrede mit einem wahlspruch der
as a beendet haben der kampftruppe der
nationalsozialisten gegen heute war
deshalb im juni strafanzeige gestellt
worden
so viele migranten wie noch nie
versuchen in diesem jahr illegal über
den ärmelkanal von frankreich nach
großbritannien zu gelangen
nun ist ein boot gekentert dabei sind
offenbar mindestens 27 menschen
ertrunken fischerboote hatten die
rettungskräfte alarmieren thomas walde
berichtet die polizei kommt zu spät
heute morgen am strand westlich von köln
als sich eine gruppe flüchtlinge auf
macht den ärmelkanal zu überqueren
männer frauen kinder
wir gehen nach großbritannien am abend
berichten französische behörden dass bei
einem überquerung versuch zahlreiche
menschen ertrunken sein es ist bislang
unklar um welches boot und um wen es
sich genau handelt frankreichs
premierminister spricht von einer
tragödie
der innenminister begebe sich nach
calais vor dem winter warten viele
migranten in calais auf ihre chance
frankreichs behörden rüsten derweil an
land auf die briten zahlen dafür beide
länder versuchen so die flucht zu
verhindern manchmal löst die polizei
auch wie vor kurzem bei den kirchen ein
wildes lager auf der druck nimmt zu der
staat erhöht die gefahr weil sich nun
statt 50 menschen in einem boot von
calais 70 menschen aufmachen von weiter
entfernten boulogne und das boot ist
nicht dafür geeignet
mehr als 23.000 menschen haben es in
diesem jahr nach drüben geschafft so
viele wie noch nie
7700 wurden aus seenot gerettet
das ist nicht nur ein französisches
problem die menschen die in calais
ankommen kommen aus verschiedenen
europäischen ländern hierher wie
deutschland großbritannien gilt bei
migranten als attraktiv wegen der
sprache der arbeitsmöglichkeiten und
weil es nach dem break cit flüchtlinge
nicht einfach in eu länder zurück
schieben könne an manchen tagen sieht
man es vom festland für einige migranten
war es heute eine tödliche verlockung
jetzt nehme ich sie mit ins all es geht
um die sicherheit von uns allen darum
die erde vor einem asteroideneinschlag
zu schützen dafür beobachten forscher
den weltraum genau und proben jetzt den
ernstfall zum ersten mal wird versucht
mit einer art sonde einen echten aber
harmlosen asteroiden in sicherer
entfernung zu beschießen die hoffnung
der auftrag und die rücklagen des
staubwolke verändern die flugbahn des
asteroiden im ernstfall wäre dass die
rettung heute ging es los in klinger hat
mir
der start der space ex falcon 9 rakete
in kalifornien lief glatt und nun ist
zum ersten mal eine sonde unterwegs ins
all die absichtlich auf einen asteroiden
prallen und ihnen so von seinem kurs
abbringen soll mit rund 20.000 km h ein
test der nasa gefährlich wäre dieser
asteroid für die erde nicht
wenn es dann mal einen asteroiden gibt
der die erde bedroht dann wollen wir
diese technik schon jahrzehnte im voraus
getestet so dass wir dem asteroiden dann
einen kleinen schubs geben was einen
großen unterschied machen wird so dass
er nicht mehr auf kollisionskurs mit der
erde sein wird bis zum kleineren eines
sogenannten doppel asteroiden wird die
sonde daad fast ein jahr unterwegs sein
um ihn auf eine neue umlaufbahn zu
stoßen
2024 folgt dann der zweite teil der
mission die esa schickt ihre sonde her
alles um den einschlagkrater zu
untersuchen und das gewicht des 160
meter großen brockens im all zu
bestimmen so lässt sich der erfolg des
anschubsen bemessen der trick ist dass
dieser impuls sehr früh erfolgen muss
wir müssen also früh eine gefährliche
situation für die erde erkennen jahre
zuvor dann reicht auch so ein kleiner
schubs um eine große wirkung zu
entfalten
dann können wir auch sicherstellen dass
die erde verfehlt wird wie gefährlich
auch kleinere asteroiden werden können
hat dieser einschlag 2013 in russland
gezeigt hier arbeiten nasa und esa an
frühwarnsystemen damit wir in zukunft
vorbereitet sind sollte ein asteroid
richtung erde rasen
champions league genau bleibt ja auch
spannend und emotional ernüchterung bei
florian co fällt nach seiner ersten
niederlage als trainer von wolfsburg der
vfl unterlag im vorletzten gruppenspiel
der königsklasse beim fc sevilla 0 2
darf aber dennoch weiter auf das
achtelfinale hoffen
nicht nur trainer gefällt hatte viel zu
bemängeln nach dem spiel herrschte
ratlosigkeit so eine schwache leistung
von lösungs und ich habe keine erklärung
warum wir absolut nicht ins spiel
reingekommen sind
das frühe 1 0 12 minute rakitic zu
schotter verunsichert die wolfsburger
dann gänzlich im gesamten spiel gelingt
ihnen nur diese eine tor chance
gefährlicher wird es offensiv nicht in
der nachspielzeit fällt dann der 2 zu 0
siegtreffer für swinger das positive
heutigen haben ist dass wir gegen wil zu
hause noch die chance haben europäische
zu überwintern danone lukas metzler der
sah wegen meckerns sein drittes gelb im
wettbewerb
der fc bayern münchen hatte ja die
achtelfinal-teilnahme bereits gesichert
und kommt nun durch das 2 2 1 in kiew
hofft als gruppen-erster weiter
weltfußballer robert lewandowski brachte
mit diesem großartigen fallrückzieher in
der 14 minute die bayern in führung am
ende der fünfte sieg im fünften spiel
bayerns josef kimmig ist positiv auf das
khroma virus getestet wurden und
befindet sich weiter in quarantäne
das bestätigte der fc bayern münchen vor
wenigen minuten sie wissen user kimmig
ist ungeimpft unter erfolgsdruck steht
am abend rb leipzig als gruppenletzter
ersatz coach achim beierlorzer zeigt
sich vor der partie beim fc gruppe
brücke hoch motiviert wir wissen noch
aus dem hinspiel wie sie uns mann gegen
mann attackiert haben und in zweikämpfe
verwickelt haben das heißt es wird ein
höchst intensives spiel darauf haben wir
uns vorbereitet darauf haben wir heute
auch die mannschaft vorbereitet und
alles zum fünften champions league
spieltag hier bei uns von 23 uhr an ins
sportstudio live sowie online auf
heute.de darunter auch die partie von
borussia dortmund bei portugals meister
sporting lissabon für die mannschaft von
trainer marco rose geht es auch dabei um
fast alles oder nichts mit einem sieg
wäre der wichtige gruppenplatz zwei
verbucht bei einer niederlage mit zwei
toren unterschied käme das aus und ein
unentschieden sei keine option so ist es
dankeschön fehlen noch jeden mittwoch
die lottozahlen sie lauten 2 59 19 24 25
und die superzahl sieben weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
beim wetter spielen frost und schnee
eine rolle welche verrät gleich aus dem
verlies danach heißt es was nun herr
habeck was nun herr lindner danke für
ihr interesse einen schönen abend noch
und bis morgen wenn sie mögen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
schon gesamte und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter schnee wird ein thema in den
nächsten tagen sein feuchte und kühle
luft erreicht uns von norden her vor
allem dann zum donnerstagmorgen ist es
noch relativ ruhig ja und das liegt
hauptsächlich an diesem hoch das lenkt
quasi auf seiner ostseite die tiefs in
unsere richtung etwas regen dann von
norden her vor allem in der kommenden
nacht dann im norden da wird es etwas
sprühregen geben sonst viele wolken im
süden klart es teilweise auf in
gewässernähe teilweise dichter nebel und
dort wo es keine wolken gibt ist es
wieder eisig kalt bis minus fünf grad
geht es runter im norden frostfrei mit
zwei bis sieben grad am mildesten in
schleswig-holstein morgen dort vor allem
viele wolken und immer wieder etwas
regen auch zur ost sehen auch richtung
emsland das zieht langsam weiter
südwärts wird aber nicht viel sein sonst
sonnenschein etwas nach süden und osten
hin teilweise auch dichter nebel mit
temperaturen von minus 1 grad unter dem
dichten nebel und 9 grad in schleswig
holstein ja und am freitag dann regen
und schnee im westen hauptsächlich dann
in den mittelgebirgen und auch im süden
schnee bei null bis fünf grad ja und
schnee auch in den nächsten tagen dann
vor allem im westen und im süden damit
ein schöner abend